j'ouvre notre second débat tout de suite
dans ce sens public comme chaque soir
cette semaine il est consacré ou le son
de la guerre en Ukraine un an après
l'invasion russe hier on vous proposait
un portrait de volody mirzelinski ce
soir on va détailler les conséquences
économiques du conflit l'inflation la
souveraineté énergétique la nouvelle
route des céréales on en parlait les
sanctions contre Poutine et les
oligarques le monde a basculé Jérôme
Rabier la guerre menée par la Russie en
Ukraine a profondément perturbé
l'économie mondiale cette année quand
les Occidentaux ont mis au bon la Russie
gros producteur de pétrole et de gaz les
prix de l'énergie ont flambée en France
la hausse a fortement impacté ménage
comme entreprise même si le gouvernement
a déployé un bouclier tarifaire pour
l'atténuer à coups de milliards d'euros
la prolongation du bouclier tarifaire
que vient d'annoncer la première
ministre Coutras 16 milliards d'euros en
2023 pourrait tout à fait précis 11
milliards d'euros pour le gaz 5
milliards d'euros pour l'électricité les
prix de l'énergie comme des intrants
agricoles ont entraîné une inflation en
particulier dans l'agriculture bilan des
courses le portefeuille des Français est
particulièrement impacté on a calculé
que
cette flambée des prix dans les dans les
magasins à l'écouter 790 euros de plus
un foyer français pour les mêmes courses
par rapport à 2021 sur un an l'inflation
est à 6% mais c'est jusqu'à 15% dans
l'alimentaire le gouvernement promet un
retour à une inflation moins élevée en
milieu d'année un optimisme partagé au
niveau européen
rising wedge la hausse des salaires et
le récent déclin de l'inflation des prix
de l'énergie devrait également atténuer
la perte de pouvoir d'achat que de
nombreuses personnes ont subi en raison
de l'inflation élevée ce qui à son tour
soutiendra la consommation
le risque d'une spirale inflationniste
n'est pas encore écarté mais le spectre
s'éloigne la France comme la zone euro
devrait avoir une croissance positive
bien que limitée cette année sauf si le
conflit ukrainien vient encore une fois
rebattre les cartes de l'économie
mondiale
je vous présente mes invités Sylvie ma
télé bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
économiste directrice adjointe de
l'Institut de relation internationale et
stratégie Patrick Martin Genier bonsoir
et bienvenue à vous aussi professeur à
Sciences Po spécialiste des questions
européennes votre livre l'Europe
a-t-elle un avenir publié chez Studyrama
Erwan Benezet bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste au service économie du
Parisien et évidemment faudrait que ça y
est resté à mes côtés éditorialistes
pour sciences publiques cette semaine
première question tient assez générale
cinématelli bon cette guerre en Ukraine
elle a évidemment transformé l'économie
mondiale on va essayer de détailler ça
45 minutes nous nous suffirons pas ça
c'est sûr mais bon à quel point ça a
fait basculer le centre de gravité de
l'économie mondiale qu'est-ce que vous
dites là-dessus
c'est une question compliquée parce que
le centre de gravité de l'économie
mondiale il était en train de basculer
du côté de l'Asie de la Chine et puis de
toute cette région asiatique qui est
extrêmement productive avec des chaînes
de valeur qui se localise de plus en
plus dans cette région une consommation
aussi sont des pays émergents qui se
développaient et c'est vrai que la
tendance de la guerre en Ukraine c'est
peut-être d'avoir rebasculé l'intérêt du
monde sur l'Europe avec l'impression
alors encore une fois ne nous trompons
pas l'économie c'est pas relocaliser en
Europe loin sans faux mais ce qui est
certain c'est que l'Europe est redevenue
un foyer de tension un foyer d'enjeux
économique avec toutes les conséquences
de la guerre et puis en même temps ce
qu'on observe aussi c'est cette
fragmentation de la mondialisation qui
s'accélère et au fond ce monde qui est
en train de se diviser alors aujourd'hui
il est très clair que ce monde il est
divisé d'un côté autour des États-Unis
de l'autre autour de la Chine
probablement sur des valeurs
démocratiques et autocratiques après qui
fait partie de ces deux mondes c'est un
peu plus compliqué les lignes sont un
petit peu plus floues et les mois qui
viennent nous ouvrirons un peu plus les
yeux espérons-le Patrick Martin Genier
l'Europe mais en tant que que
qu'organisation finalement
on est face à on parle de succession de
crise ou de multicrises on a on a eu la
pandémie qui s'est croisé enchaîné avec
cette cette crise née de la guerre en
Ukraine est-ce que l'Europe vous semble
économiquement plus soudée aujourd'hui
qu'avant ces deux crises écoutez je
pense en tout cas à la lecture des 10
trains de sanction le dixième va être
adopté normalement à la fin de ce mois
que l'Europe a été extraordinairement
soudée ça c'est important au début on
avait dit que certains états étaient
contre on a vu l'Allemagne qui était
hésitant tu as encore effectivement
Victor Orban pour la Hongrie qui est
contre mais enfin globalement on a quand
même adopté à l'unanimité un train de
sanctions considérable et je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui que ça touche et ça
affecte considérablement cette économie
même si nous manquons de recul et de
statistiques les économistes vont vous
dire on n'est pas de l'impact de section
mais en tout cas les cinq choses
économiques il y a aussi un impact
psychologique et politique dire que par
exemple la banque centrale de Russie ne
peut plus disposer de ces 680 milliards
de dollars de réserve de 2 euros pardon
de réserve à l'extérieur à l'étranger
c'est important parce que c'est quelque
chose qui soutient à l'économie et donc
il y a un impact politique l'Europe a
été extraordinairement soudé et on peut
dire qu'à toute chose malheur est bon
malheureusement c'est qu'effectivement
l'Europe s'est réveillée elle a vu
qu'elle était fragile non seulement d'un
point de vue politique mais également
d'un point de vue économique et je pense
qu'elle a réussi avec courage même si on
ne peut pas exclure certaines certaines
hésitations certaines fractures dans les
mois les années qui viennent et Erwan
même question un peu autour de l'Europe
est-ce qu'elle vous a étonné finalement
par sa capacité d'adaptation ou de
réaction elle a quand même fait preuve
d'une résilience extrêmement importante
on a eu peur au début ce qu'on a vu
quand même effectivement des vous
parliez de de centres de gravité on a vu
quand même l'Allemagne en France un
petit peu le se fissurer s'opposer sur
certaines choses aujourd'hui encore il y
a des sujets comme par exemple l'achat
groupé de gaz qui devait être lancés au
mois de mars et rien n'est sûr donc ça a
pris du temps aussi sur la
l'intervention
ou l'aide militaire voilà il y a
vraiment on était d'accord sur certaines
choses pas d'accord sur d'autres et puis
finalement il y a quand même une forte
résilience juste sur l'énergie cette
capacité à se mettre ensemble dans la
course à remplir les stockages de gaz
pour l'hiver 2022 2023 et puis donc à
complètement réorienter les flux de test
West et de les réorienter dans l'autre
sens d'ouest en est avec donc le GNL le
gaz naturel liquéfié la construction
terminée comme on l'a vu en Allemagne
voilà tout ça a pris un petit peu de
temps on a eu peur d'une fissuration de
de l'Europe et puis finalement elle
tient bon si je caricature si on n'a pas
de coupure d'électricité cette hiver
c'est en partie grâce à l'Europe soucis
en partie un petit peu grâce au climat
mais oui quand même il y a les choses
ont été
mais il faut le dire aussi un peu de
chance et en même temps on a eu mais la
chance elle se provoque et on l'a aussi
provoqué Patrick
on a quand même réussi à avoir des
stocks de gaz considérables dès le mois
de septembre n'occupe était pratiquement
plein les réserves et donc c'est cela
également grâce à cette politique
énergétique de l'Europe historiquement
haute on est au-delà de 60% du
remplissage des stockages ce qui a à ce
moment de l'année alors certes donc le
le l'hiver extrêmement doux et voilà il
y a eu toute la logistique qui a été
mise en place qui aujourd'hui paie si
l'humatisme
pro-européen qui a aucun débat critique
mais force de constater moi il y a un
chiffre qui m'a quand même étonné au
mois de janvier rappelez-vous quand la
guerre a commencé on s'est dit oh mon
dieu c'est la fin de c'est la fin de
l'Europe on va pas s'en sortir c'est
vrai qu'on a été unicérée qu'on a été
soudée mais encore mieux que ça regardez
les chiffres de croissance dans le monde
l'Europe a dépassé en 2022 la croissance
américaine et la croissance chinoise
pour des raisons très différentes les
unes des autres mais au début de la
guerre on aurait plutôt pensé que
c'était les États-Unis qui allaient très
bien s'en sortir et finalement le mot
résilience et le bon mot encore une fois
je sais pas ce que va être 2023 et sans
tomber dans un dans un sentiment
pro-européen un peu naïf il n'empêche
que en 2022 l'Europe a su être solidaire
à surester soudé et les résultats
économiques sont là et on a affronté le
prix du gaz rappelez-vous nos
entreprises le paie quatre à cinq fois
plus que les entreprises américaines
donc c'est pas rien on a traversé cette
année 2022 avec des capacités à
combattre la difficulté qui sont quand
même assez étonnantes alors il y a
beaucoup de conséquences et de leçons
économiques à tirer de de ce conflit on
va commencer par l'inflation évidemment
qui est peut-être celui voilà qui nous
impactent tous dans notre quotidien elle
s'élevait sur les 12 mois de
de l'année écoulé 8 et demi pour cent
sur un an dans la zone euro et 6 % en
France notre pays je reste avec vous si
le mateli plutôt mieux protégé alors
c'est quoi c'est le quoi qu'il en coûte
qui a continué c'est aussi simple que ça
oui je crois que c'est le quoi continuer
alors c'est assez amusant parce que il y
a une sorte d'obsession au sein de du
gouvernement français qui est le gilet
jaune et le risque de révolte sociale et
on a le quoi qu'il en coûte à servi à
éviter ça ce qui est assez amusant c'est
que cette cette peur du gilet jaune est
arrivé jusqu'à Bruxelles ou dans les
couloirs à Bruxelles au moment de la
guerre en Ukraine tout le monde se
disait oh là là il faut absolument agir
contre cette augmentation des prix de
l'énergie parce qu'on va tout savoir des
gilets jaunes chez nous donc on a on a
c'est vrai on a agi mais on a été assez
rapidement suivi par les pays voisins
qui avaient conscience aussi des
difficultés que pouvait engendrer cette
guerre en Ukraine
le cette inflation cette os du cette
baisse du pouvoir d'achat ressenti par
tous les Français on a tous ressenti ça
a commencé par les hydrocarbures ça
s'est étendu à d'autres produits ça pèse
si on essaye de regarder les
hydrocarbures c'est toujours ce qui pèse
le plus dans dans l'inflation la moitié
dans l'inflation la moitié d'accord
ensuite il y a eu effectivement le le
poids de des matières premières qui a
qui on a pensé qu'il allait prendre le
relais et puis finalement les prix de
l'énergie on son rester très très haut
même si ça ça a un petit peu baissé pour
l'instant mais donc c'était en tout cas
déjà 2022 la moitié de l'inflation
venait de l'énergie c'est l'étincelle
même qui a son jeu de mots qui a qui a
fait flamber les prix et on a été
effectivement protégé bouclier tarifaire
pour l'électricité le gaz rabais sur le
carburant et puis la hausse des des des
des des aides sociales
qui qui a effectivement protégé le le la
France mais ça a coûté 40 milliards de
d'euros en 2022 Patrick oui vous avez
tout à fait raison et il faut dire qu'en
France nous avons une tradition étatiste
interventionniste qui tranche par
rapport aux autres pays le Royaume-Uni
qui n'est plus dans l'Union européenne
mais enfin refuse absolument de négocier
quelques hausse de salaire que ce soit
de protéger les consommateurs les
citoyens à telle sorte que il y a plus
de 10 millions 15 millions de foyers qui
aujourd'hui sont au seuil de la pauvreté
énergétique et vous citiez Bruxelles
mais en Belgique on n'a pas voulu non
plus nécessairement donc limité c'est
hausse et en Italie c'est à peu près la
même chose tout dépend de la conception
idéologique qu'on les gouvernements de
l'interventionnisme économique alors
justement il fallait que c'est
intéressant parce que vous vous êtes
vous penché sur ces pays qui ont connu
des mouvements sociaux alors que c'était
pas forcément dans leurs habitudes comme
ça prenez l'Allemagne par exemple à la
suite de cette inflation c'est vrai que
dans le cliché collectif on pense
d'abord à un pays qui aime plutôt
négocier il y a la cogestion dans les
entreprises les syndicats les patronats
discutent en tout cas il y a pas les
manifestations récurrentes parfois
violentes qu'on a nous en France et
pourtant et pourtant dans ce contexte
l'inflation majeure en Allemagne c'est
8% l'an dernier l'inflation ça ravivait
les tensions sociales ça rallumait la
mèche de la contestation ces dernières
semaines à la poste allemande de la
touche post qui est un organisme privé
pour le coup en Allemagne les grèves se
sont multipliées vendredi dernier les
aéroports cette fois-ci 8 aéroport en
Allemagne ont été totalement bloqués par
les salariés motivent de la grève
écouter ce responsable syndical
[Musique]
donc grève aujourd'hui à l'aéroport de
Francfort parce que c'est une grève du
service public qui inclut aussi
l'aéroport bien sûr et nous demandons
10,5% d'augmentation de salaire nous
sommes à un point où nous n'avons plus
d'options le changement climatique est
une réalité quotidienne dans de
nombreuses régions du monde voilà
blocage des aéroports en Allemagne
au Royaume-Uni également la situation
sociale c'est détérioré ces derniers
mois alors il y a le brexit toujours un
il y a cette donnée qu'il faut pas
oublier mais pas seulement car ce sont
bien les factures d'énergie dont
l'envoler est liée au conflit en Ukraine
qui ont été le point déclencheur de
cette colère vous avez vu qu'il y a même
eu un mouvement social qui appelait à ne
plus payer les factures le fameux don't
papy Bill le gouvernement a dû débloquer
en urgence des aides mais la
protestation se poursule se poursuit
encore d'ailleurs dans de nombreux
secteurs comme à l'hôpital public
la raison pour laquelle je suis ici et
en grève et parce que nous lutons en
tant que profession pour recruter et
retenir notre salaire n'a pas suivi le
rythme de l'inflation
cela a pour effet de compromettre le
nombre d'infirmières que nous avons dans
les services ce qui compromet les soins
au patient et je pense maintenant que la
plupart d'entre nous connaissent
probablement quelqu'un ou entendu une
histoire horrible sur des soins
médiocres dispensés dans l'un de nos
services hospitaliers à l'échelle
nationale
et c'est absolument dû au fait qu'il n'y
a pas assez d'infirmières
cet hiver aussi en République tchèque au
Portugal bref un peu partout avec des
gouvernements justement soumis
politiquement à cette pression qui vient
d'en bas avec un dilemme en plus comment
donner des aides comment aider les gens
à vivre sans entretenir l'inflation on
sait que ça peut parfois être aussi une
spirale cette crise passion politique et
économique elle n'est pas pour déplaire
à un certain Vladimir Poutine ce matin
et ils disent alors citoyens nous
l'entendons que c'est la Russie qui est
responsable de tout
voilà Vladimir Poutine qui voit
l'inflation comme une des conséquences
indirectes de cette guerre et de
l'engagement des pays européens un effet
collatéral entre guillemets dans ce dans
ce conflit un poison lent aux
conséquences politiques qui sont encore
devant nous évidemment merci Frédéric je
voudrais qu'on revienne à la situation
en France il y a face à cette inflation
il y a certaines professions qui sont
devenues un peu emblématiques tiens le
23 janvier dernier manifestation des
boulangers à Paris contre la hausse des
prix de l'énergie situation intenable
comme pour ce couple venu de Montpellier
on les écoute 6,2
6,21 pour rentrer seulement dans nos
charges à le calcul a été fait on a
longuement réfléchi on nous a dit qu'il
fallait la vendre à ce prix là mais bon
c'est impensable c'est impensable
faut que le pain reste abordable de
[Musique]
l'âme bateau
voilà il répondait à la question
évidemment à quel prix faudrait-il que
vous vendiez la baguette pour faire face
à cette inflation
les boulangers il y a eu aussi beaucoup
d'artisans de patron de PME qui ont été
aidés sauf que là on est en train de
voir depuis quelques jours qu'il y a des
chiffres de de faillite qui sont en
forte augmentation donc
il y a plusieurs facteurs évidemment
comment l'explique alors c'est toute la
crainte les boulangers je suis allé à
leur rencontre j'avais fait un reportage
dans l'Orne à la rencontre d'un
boulanger qui était quasiment le dernier
lieu de vie et d'échange du village avec
le coiffeur donc ça symboliquement une
importance très forte notamment dans les
milieux ruraux et le problème c'est que
le gouvernement a
mis en place différents mécanismes
d'aide puis il y avait toujours des
trous dans la raquette et un moment on
s'est rendu compte que notamment les
artisans et les boulangers pour de des
raisons par exemple de puissance de
compteurs qui étaient au-delà de 36
kilos vols a alors il n'avait pas le
droit pas oublier tarifaires puis alors
ensuite donc on a mis d'autres
mécanismes comme l'amortisseur
électricité etc un peu des usines à gaz
là aussi sans jeux de mots et donc
c'était très compliqué et vous avez
aujourd'hui encore effectivement des
artisans qui ne savent pas comment
résoudre l'équation entre ne pas
augmenter le prix de leurs produits et
faire face à des coûts qui flambent sur
juste sur les boulangers
notamment dans l'ordre où j'étais allé
on voyait dans les vitrines des
boulangeries le cours du blé et quand on
leur demandait mais pourquoi vous avez
affiché ça c'est pour expliquer à mes
clients que quand j'augmente de 20
centimes le prix de la baguette c'est
parce que derrière moi le prix du blé
bah je le paye deux fois plus cher
qu'auparavant par exemple Sylvie
matérial est-ce que la route des
céréales elle a été en partie redessinée
par par la guerre en Ukraine oui en
partie surtout qui a eu pendant un
certain temps le blocage dans la mer
Noire dans la mer Noire qui a empêché la
sortie de blé d'Ukraine on est en train
de s'adapter mais c'est vrai que ce qui
s'est passé en 2022 et je crois que la
résilience de nos économies est quand
même assez extraordinaire c'est que vous
avez eu une guerre en Ukraine qui arrive
qui accroît une inflation qui était déjà
galopante sur l'énergie sur les matières
premières après les
déconfinements et
l'accélération de la croissance
économique après la pandémie donc vous
avez eu des crises en fait une crise qui
démarre alors que l'autre n'est pas
encore terminée donc c'est vrai que vous
avez une augmentation massive des prix
et du prix d'énergie il est évident que
l'énergie a été très bon marché pendant
très longtemps et que ça ne durera pas
et qu'il faut s'adapter à cette
situation où l'énergie va coûter plus
cher et qui dit énergie qui coûte plus
cher c'est aussi les un certain nombre
de matières premières dont les produits
agricoles qui coûtent plus cher il
n'empêche que ce qu'on a vécu en 2022
était quand même assez extraordinaire
mais ça veut dire je viens vers vous
juste après mais que ce changement
finalement alors nouvelle route des
céréales nouvelles habit début de sur le
marché de l'énergie ils sont ils sont
profonds ils sont durs on reviendra pas
forcément en arrière parce qu'on
pourrait se dire bon bah c'est une
guerre elle va durer malheureusement le
peut-être encore plus longtemps mais et
ensuite on reviendra à nos habitudes
précédentes vous dites non en fait
chaque crise et ça a toujours été le cas
chaque crise nous fait changer nos
habitudes lorsque la crise se termine ou
lorsque les conséquences de la crise
s'atténue on revient un petit peu en
arrière mais malgré tout on a quand même
changé nos habitudes et au fur et à
mesure des crises c'est vrai que la
façon dont nous vivons aujourd'hui dont
nous nous approvisionnons aujourd'hui
n'a plus rien à voir avec ce qui se
passait ne serait-ce qu'au début des
années 90 c'est pas le moyen-âge donc on
voit qu'on est dans ces évolutions
aujourd'hui on est confronté qui plus
est à un certain nombre de défis majeurs
c'est le questionnement sur la
mondialisation la sécurisation nos
chaînes de valeurs c'est le
questionnement sur le changement
climatique bien évidemment sur la
répartition de la valeur et les
inégalités sur la complexité croissante
des relations intern professionnel donc
ça ce sont des phénomènes qui sont
potentiellement décrises sauf si on s'y
prépare mais si préparé ça veut dire
aussi changer nos habitudes sera très
clair sur le prix de l'énergie juste
pour terminer là-dessus mais sur le prix
de l'énergie cette énergie qui va coûter
de plus en plus cher c'est la
conséquence de la transition énergétique
on le sait depuis 30 ans on le sait
depuis 30 ans c'est pas une surprise
comment se fait-il qu'on se soit
retrouvé aussi mal préparé au moment de
la crise de la guerre en Ukraine ça
c'est une vraie question la sobriété
dans notre premier débat sur l'eau ça
vaut aussi évidemment sur sur l'énergie
Patrick Martin Genier si on fait un peu
le bilan de parce que c'est aussi à ça
que
certes cette semaine spéciale dans dans
ce sens public ce bilan des 12 mois de
guerre on a craint une famine à une
époque oui cette question des céréales
on disait finalement le blocus il a été
levé c'était au mois de juillet si je me
souviens vous avez raison on a créé une
famine mondiale surtout dans les pays en
voie développement pauvre comme en
Afrique mais vous savez un jour il sera
intéressant de faire le bilan de cet
accord céréalier parce que je ne suis
pas qu'il est répondu aux objectifs par
exemple on sait très bien que la Turquie
a beaucoup acheté que certains pays qui
n'avaient pas à prioritairement besoin
ont acheté et donc j'aimerais bien
savoir qu'il y a eu un peu de
spéculation et la spéculation il y a eu
du trafic et naturellement je suis pas
certain que les pays d'Afrique qui en
avaient le plus besoin et puis l'obtenir
les seuls dont on est sûr c'est les
bâtons des bâtons des nations uniques
avaient été affrétées par Antonio
Guterres c'est ce que tu as un général
des Nations unies qui a pu effectivement
être affrêter pour ces pays mais je ne
suis pas certain que ces pays ont pu en
profiter et la famille contrairement à
ce qu'on croit continu dans certaines
parties de l'Afrique notamment dans
l'Afrique de l'Est a augmenté là la
situation
et donc il y a la sécheresse la guerre
et malheureusement il y a toute une
série de trafic qui fait que certains
pays et bien ne bénéficient pas de cet
accord céréalier simplement pour
terminer
l'augmentation du coût de la vis n'est
pas uniquement l'augmentation du coût
énergétique mais vous savez des
économistes ont montré que le coût du
panier de consommation de base moyen
avait augmenté de 30% dans nos économies
aussi ce qui veut dire que les ménages
les plus modestes souffrent aussi de
cette crise économique certes nous
n'avons pas de famine heureusement mais
il y a eu quand même des conséquences
très importantes mais alors ça il faut
expliquer parce qu'il y a un décalage
entre ce que vous nous dites et les
chiffres de l'inflation qu'on a donné
tout à l'heure là vous dit 30 % du
panier moyen et l'inflation en France
justement souvent il y a une inertie et
l'impact on le voit maintenant par
exemple ce matin l'Insee publie des
chiffres je crois que c'était ce matin
sur le fait que les Français ont diminué
leurs achats de 9% dans le l'alimentaire
alimentaire c'est le coup direct de
l'inflation alors pour l'instant ils
n'ont pas baissé en volume leurs achats
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'ils
achètent des produits qui coûtent moins
cher donc ils vont se rabattre sur des
marques de
des marques des magasins distributeurs
etc mais pour l'instant le peut-être le
second étage la fusée c'est quand ils
vont commencer vraiment à serrer la
ceinture et là acheter moins et donc
manger moins sur
encore des céréales et ça rejoint votre
question d'avance sur qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est un an de guerre en
Ukraine on peut changer de de choc sur
les céréales effectivement 30% du du blé
était produit par l'Ukraine et par la
Russie et puis on a craint la famille
auquel vous pouvez à laquelle vous
faisiez allusion tout à l'heure et donc
des pays ont pris le relais je pense à
l'Argentine je pense au Brésil au Canada
à l'Australie pour nourrir effectivement
des zones géographiques qui risquaient
la famine qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que il y a le
l'aspect de mondialisation avec des
approvisionnements qui se font
uniquement dans des dans des zones très
spécifiques ça c'est en train de changer
et ça change depuis 2008 et la première
crise financière c'est-à-dire à l'époque
19% du PIB mondial provenait des
exportations aujourd'hui on est en
dessous de 17%. donc on assiste non pas
une démondialisation mais on assiste
quand même à un phénomène où on va
essayer ou les pays vont tenter de ne
plus mettre tous les œufs dans un même
panier ça se voit sur les céréales ça se
voit sur l'énergie et ça se voit sur de
nombreuses choses même les
semi-conducteurs par exemple et là c'est
un autre mot évidemment essentiel dans
un débat comme celui-là le mode
souveraineté on reste sur ce sur
l'inflation parce que on est en train et
on a dû choisir de de voilà de mettre en
lumière les bouleversements économiques
liés à cette guerre en Ukraine il y a
évidemment l'attitude des banques
centrales aussi qui ont totalement
changé de Pierre remonter leur taux
d'intérêt c'est la fin de décennie
d'argent pas cher tiens on va écouter
c'était le 2 février dernier il y a
quelques jours la présidente de la
Banque centrale européenne Christine
Lagarde elle maintient ce CAP
le Conseil des gouverneur de la BCE
maintiendra le cap en augmentant les
taux d'intérêt à un rythme régulier et
en les maintenant à des niveaux
suffisamment restrictifs pour assurer un
retour rapide de l'inflation vers notre
objectif à moyen terme de 2 %. médium
Patrick Martin Genier l'objectif de
Christine Lagarde dans la bien compris
c'est de freiner l'inflation puis
éventuellement de la faire reculer de la
ramener
un objectif de 2%, c'est quoi son si on
fait un peu de de
d'équilibre européen c'est quoi son
pouvoir au sein des instances
européennes centrale européenne c'est
d'abord de maîtriser l'inflation donc
les taux d'intérêt c'est son rôle
essentiel elle n'a pas de responsabilité
en matière de politique budgétaire mais
elle est là pour maîtriser les finances
publiques à travers les banques
centrales nationales et donc pour
limiter l'inflation et donc les
liquidités c'est ça son rôle elle a un
rôle très important bien évidemment mais
c'est le rôle de la Banque centrale
européenne comme c'est le rôle de la
Banque centrale aux États-Unis
cadre là finalement la Banque centrale
européenne elle est beaucoup plus
dépendante de ce que fait la Réserve
fédérale des États-Unis que de ce que
voudrait qu'elle fasse telle ou telle
gouvernement européen pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui ici les États-Unis et
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait la Réserve
fédérale américaine augmente ses taux
d'intérêt un investisseur la signature
américaine c'est la meilleure des
signatures avant que les États-Unis
alors je dis pas que les États-Unis
feront jamais défaut mais avant que les
États-Unis fassent défaut il peut se
passer quand même un certain temps donc
un investisseur quand il s'aperçoit que
l'argent est mieux rémunéré aux
États-Unis et qu'en plus le placement
américain est un placement peu risqué il
y a pas photo il part aux États-Unis
investir tous ses capitaux donc pour
éviter ça que doit faire les banques
centrales quand elles peuvent le faire
c'est augmenter leur taux d'intérêt pour
s'assurer que ces capitaux vont rester
qu'il va rester intéressant dans
l'arbitrage rendement risque il va
rester intéressant de rester en Europe
alors en Europe on est bien servi parce
qu'on a la zone euro parce qu'on est on
est une zone crédible en fait on n'a pas
trop peur de la faillite ou d'un défaut
européen donc on a augmenté notre taux
d'intérêt mais à peu près en parallèle
de ce qu'on fait les Américains
c'est-à-dire dans une marge relativement
limitée c'est pas du tout le cas dans
des pays où l'inflation est beaucoup
plus forte et dans des pays qui sont
beaucoup plus exposés aux risques vous
avez des pays qui ont dû augmenter leur
taux de la des 10 % 10 15 20 % pour
préserver les investissements locaux et
encore ça n'a pas toujours fonctionné et
il y a quelque chose qui est très
intéressant dans ce contexte là c'est
qu'on a vu le Fond Monétaire
International ça n'inquiétait en disant
attention il y a des pays qui sont très
endettés cette augmentation des des taux
d'intérêt elle pèse sur la dette
publique de ces états-là et un autre
acteur qui ça n'est profondément
inquiété parce qu'il est très très
exposé c'est la Chine la Chine qui a
prêté massivement depuis une dizaine
d'années à un certain nombre de pays
émergents et de pays du Sud qui doivent
augmenter très fortement leur taux
d'intérêt et aujourd'hui la Chine
s'inquiète du défaut de ces pays alors
il y a ces conséquences macroéconomiques
et puis il y a des conséquences à Erwan
Benezet alors beaucoup plus quotidienne
pour les Français qui voudraient acheter
ou vendre un bien c'est que le marché de
l'immobilier il est en il est temps
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on dit en crise
où est-ce que le mot est un peu
ralentissement il est en ralentissement
et vous avez raison il y a des
conséquences macroéconomiques et je
dirais conséquences à long terme et à
court terme et à long terme là sur
l'immobilier on est sur une connaissance
non pas à court terme mais en une
conséquence immédiate on le voit là et
après la conséquence la plus long terme
c'est effectivement la banque centrale
c'est une sorte de pilote dans la
tempête avec un curseur et parfois il
est un peu entre le marteau et l'enclume
le marteau c'est l'inflation l'enclume
c'est c'est le ralentissement de la
croissance ou le décrochage de la
croissance on peut voir les chiffres
d'ailleurs de la croissance en Europe
pendant que vous parlez vous pouvez
continuer elle est si on est on est dans
une stagne stagnation au 4e on a frôlé
la la la déflation pour l'instant on est
en train de d'y échapper mais on a
quasiment à 0 % 0 1% de croissance et
donc le le le le curseur enfin le le
pilotage c'est extrêmement fin et le
problème donc on parlait du court terme
avec l'immobilier et donc l'impact
immédiat notamment sur les Français mais
à plus long terme le risque ça serait un
décrochage de compétitivité avec un
argent qui coûtera plus cher donc moins
d'investissements pour les entreprises
l'industrie un risque de délocalisation
notamment liée à l'énergie d'industrie
qui sont implantés en Europe et qui
partiraient ailleurs notamment aux
États-Unis un chimiste comme
BASF à a dit qu'il allait réduire son
implantation en Europe et tout ça pour
pardon chimiste allemand chimiste
allemand tout à fait et donc pour faire
la boucle avec la question vous me
posiez c'est que bah derrière ça va être
des emplois et donc dans ces cas-là ça
risque d'être moins d'emplois un taux de
chômage qui réaugmente et donc tout à
l'heure on faisait un peu d'angélisme
sur la manière dont la résilience de
l'Europe c'est effectivement pour
l'instant elle est très fort à l'instant
T mais on est prudent pour la suite on
est prudent pour la suite et notamment
le rôle des banques centrales auquel
vous faisiez allusion il va être très
important
aussi ceux des livrets livré j'ai vu que
la collecte était énorme ce mois-ci
qu'elle avait jamais été aussi forte en
France en tout cas depuis 2009 comment
on l'explique à part les taux
myoruminérateur c'est aussi une crainte
de l'avenir alors tout effectivement
tout à fait quand les Français
commencent à épargner c'est que ils
peuvent craindre pour l'avenir ce que
vous disiez et donc ils vont se
raccrocher à des valeurs refuge mais
pour les pays d'une manière
macroéconomique c'est souvent l'or et
d'ailleurs on le voit actuellement et
Ben et d'un point de vue microéconomique
effectivement ça peut être sur des des
investissements qui rassurent
l'immobilier tendra en train de ralentir
la pierre on se dit que c'est peut-être
pas aussi intéressant et donc on va
aller sur d'autres
épargnes comme le livret A alors cette
inflation est-ce qu'elle va durer je
vous propose la réaction l'analyse du
commissaire européen à l'économie Paolo
gentiloni
[Musique]
l'inflation a continué à augmenter plus
rapidement que prévu mais nous pensons
que le pic est proche très probablement
à la fin de cette année nous prévoyons
que l'inflation atteindra 9,3% dans
l'Union européenne et 8,5% dans la zone
euro et qu'elle ne décélèrera que
légèrement l'année prochaine pour
atteindre 7% et 6,1% avant de diminuer
plus fortement en 2024
alors on a bien compris il y a cerise
inflationniste et puis il y a le risque
évidemment de de stagnation de la
croissance je redonne les chiffres à un
taux de croissance de la zone euro au
quatrième trimestre de l'année 2022 0,1%
et taux de croissance dans l'Union
européenne ce même quatrième c'est 0% si
l'humatisme si on essaye de se projeter
avec voilà ces perspectives de là vous
regardez il est sympa de me poser cette
question
de croissance et puis ce que nous dit le
commissaire européen sur sur l'inflation
est-ce que effectivement on est dans une
perspective quand même de retour à la
normale au niveau inflationniste ça fait
trois ans qu'on entend depuis le retour
de l'inflation qu'on entend dans 6 mois
c'est en retour à la normale je crois
qu'il y a deux phénomènes il y a le
phénomène guerre en Ukraine et situation
totalement imprévues qui fait que les
anticipations parlaient tout à l'heure
de spéculation le prix du gaz par
exemple il a essentiellement augmenté au
premier semestre 2022 parce que les
marchés du gaz étaient spéculatifs parce
qu'on anticipait une énorme crise en
Europe et puis ils ont baissé à l'été
parce que les stocks de gaz se
remplissaient et qu'on s'est dit
finalement la crise n'aura pas de de des
prix du gaz 338 euros le megawattheure
en août 2022 et là aujourd'hui on est à
moins de 50 euros donc ça faisait
vraiment ça illustre ce que vous voulez
cet aspect instabilité qui crée de
l'attention qui crée une anticipation
une anticipation qui amplifie les
phénomènes et puis il y a le phénomène
véritablement transition énergétique et
changement de modèle qui fait que on va
probablement avoir sur les dix années
qui viennent en fait des inflations un
petit peu plus élevées que ce qu'on
avait jusque là alors en Europe on n'est
jamais parvenu au à l'objectif des 2% en
été toujours en dessous en fait donc là
on sera peut-être à deux et demi 3% et
il faudra gérer ce 2 et demi 3% parce
que ça pèse plus sur les dettes
publiques comme privées mais bien
évidemment on devrait revenir dans une
situation normalité alors je dis on
devrait parce que ça va quand même
dépendre de la suite de la guerre en
Ukraine de la confrontation entre la
Chine et les États-Unis qui ont quand
même tendance à créer aussi des
instabilités des incertitudes des crises
régulières etc etc donc voilà c'est je
peux pas vous répondre à ce jour ça
dépendra du chemin qu'on prend est-ce
que c'est un chemin de confrontation et
de crise où est-ce qu'on va essayer
enfin de travailler ensemble et de
penser à l'avenir il nous reste une
dizaine de minutes dans ce débat et on
va parler des sanctions contre la Russie
de leur de leur effet je vous propose un
extrait c'était l'un des événements de
cette journée le discours de Vladimir
Poutine 1h45 de on va dire de diatribe
antioxydantale l'affirmation que
l'économie russe résiste aux effets des
sanctions on a choisi cet extrait de
nombreux secteurs civils essentiels de
l'économie n'ont pas connu de baisse
mais même une augmentation de la
production
nous avons produit plus de 100 millions
de mètres carrés de logement l'année
dernière pour la première fois
ça a été une croissance supérieure à 10%
nous avons réduit le chômage
malgré toutes les difficultés que nous
avons rencontrées le marché de l'emploi
se trouve mieux aujourd'hui que par le
passé
Patrick Martin geni vous avez commencé à
en parler tout à l'heure mais moi je me
souviens de nos débats dans les premiers
mois de ce de ce conflit où on disait
l'économie russe elle est quand même
résiliente elle s'était adaptée à
d'autres sanctions c'était déjà une
économie qui avait du subir des
sanctions là à un an de bilan vous dites
quoi vous dites quand même qu'elle a
elle a souffert elle a d'abord vous
aurez remarqué que le public devenant
Poutine n'avait pas l'air très convaincu
parce qu'il disait donc qui capte la
parole en quelque sorte mais vous savez
c'est extrêmement difficile parce que
les statistiques officielles peuvent
être cachés on n'a pas la vérité de ce
qui se passe il est vrai j'ai officiel
c'est une contraction de moins 2% mais
ça peut être bien plus on ne sera
peut-être que plus tard mais il est vrai
que dans les premiers mois de la guerre
les sanctions économiques européennes
n'ont pas été particulièrement efficaces
au contraire on a vu une augmentation
considérable des recettes d'exportation
de gaz de pétrole jusqu'à ce que
l'Europe prenne progressivement une
série de sanctions et il est vrai aussi
que on nous a toujours dit
aura un impact sur les consommateurs
russes nous n'avons pas vu des manques
de nourriture de produits de
consommation courantes et en fait il y a
un espèce géopolitique très important
faut jamais oublier que la Russie c'est
un sous-continent à elle toute seule
donc ça veut dire ok elle a les moyens
de subsistance elle a les moyens d'être
client que l'Europe d'elle alors
premièrement elle a des moyens de vivre
on va en parler tout de suite et ensuite
effectivement elle a d'autres clients en
ailleurs et donc la Russie effectivement
on peut dire qu'elle est un peu
résiliente mais quand même aujourd'hui
on sent qu'il y a des difficultés
notamment sur les produits de pointe de
technologie qui impactent l'économie
rustre alors ça m'offre la transition
pour accueillir de nouveaux termes
traduits sur ce plateau rebonsoir Tim
puisqu'on va parler des des alliés de la
Russie sur quel soutient Vladimir
Poutine peut-il encore compter alors on
va commencer par l'Europe et en Europe
c'est assez simple il n'y a pas vraiment
grand monde pour soutenir la Russie à
l'exception de la Biélorussie qui se
comporte en vassal fidèle pour Alexandre
lucachenko dont le pays accueille les
décollages des avions Russ les
combattant russe et Bélarus sont engagés
ensemble dans la guerre écoutez
nous avons en fait une seule armée le
regroupement de nos troupes du Belarus
et de la Russie est une armée unique
c'est pourquoi j'ai soutenu et
continuerai de soutenir la Russie
autre allié on trouve aussi des vrais
soutiens à Vladimir Poutine en Amérique
latine dans des pays qui se distinguent
par leur opposition aux États-Unis comme
le Venezuela le Nicaragua ou encore Cuba
d'ailleurs le président cubain est l'un
des rares dirigeants avoir fait le
déplacement jusqu'en Russie depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine au mois de
novembre les deux présidents ont je cite
dit leur opposition à l'Empire Yankee
qu'ils ont qualifié d'ennemis commun et
puis il y a aussi le cas du Brésil qui
est intéressant qui a beaucoup changé
depuis l'élection de Lula qui veut
rompre avec l'isolement diplomatique lié
à la présidence de bolsonaro mais sur la
question russe ce n'est pas le cas il
n'y a pas pour l'instant de volte-face
la Russie reste un partenaire économique
essentiel et les deux présidents
successifs sont opposés aux sanctions
occidentales et à l'envoi d'armes et
Vladimir Poutine a aussi des soutiens en
Orient Bachar el-Assad a soutenu
immédiatement l’invasion de l'Ukraine il
a souligné je le cite encore le bien
fondé de l'opération la série est un
allié fidèle d'autant plus que le
soutient russe depuis 2015 au régime de
Damas a joué un rôle majeur c'est le
tournant qui a permis à Bachar el-Assad
de se maintenir au pouvoir dans la
région on peut également citer le fait
que Poutine peut compter sur l'Iran qui
a lui ce pays fournit des drones pour
bombarderies et puis alors il y a des
soutiens plus prudents plus discret une
sorte de neutralité bienveillante on va
dire ça voilà on l'a vu lors du vote
d'avril 2022 lors duquel l'Assemblée
générale des Nations Unies a excluent la
réussite du Conseil des droits de
l'homme il y a eu 58 pays qui se sont
abstenus parmi lesquels de nombreux
États africains d'ailleurs il y a deux
jours un Vladimir Poutine les a
qualifiés de partenaires sur et
important la Russie capitalise dans nos
pays africains sur le sentiment
antioxydantal et Sergueï lavrof a fait
pas moins de deux tournées en Afrique en
6 mois et dans les nôtres bienveillants
on trouve aussi l'un de l'un de qui a
joué à un jeu trouble depuis le début de
la guerre en Ukraine le 16 septembre le
Premier ministre indien a déclaré que
l'heure n'est pas à la guerre et au mois
de janvier il a acheté pour 500
milliards de systèmes de défense
anti-aérienne russe à Poutine en visite
officielle en Inde reste enfin le cas de
la Chine écoutez ce qu'a déclaré
aujourd'hui le ministre des Affaires
étrangères chinois
nous continuerons à promouvoir le
dialogue de paix à offrir la sagesse
chinoise pour le règlement politique de
la crise ukrainienne et travailler avec
la communauté internationale pour
promouvoir le dialogue et la
consultation répondre aux inquiétudes de
toutes les parties et chercher la
sécurité commune voilà donc à priori une
position médiane un appel à la paix mais
qui intervient alors qu'il y a deux
jours seulement le secrétaire d'État
américain Anthony blinken a déclaré que
Pékin envisageait de fournir des armes à
la Russie pour appuyer son offensive en
Ukraine merci beaucoup Tam Sylvie Mattei
c'est je sais pas quelle expérience
employée c'est presque un peu le fond
d'écran de cette année quoi le le bras
de fer c'est un cliché mais entre les
États-Unis et la Chine on peut pas
analyser le bilan de ces de ces 12 mois
de guerre sans sans parler de ça c'est
clair c'est c'est véritablement le fond
d'écran mais je crois qu'il y a un autre
fond d'écran qui s'est superposé et qui
s'appuie sur cette rivalité Chine
États-Unis c'est ce qu'on vient de dire
c'est ce fameux Sud global tous ces pays
du étude qui sans
valider ce qu'a fait la Russie parce
qu'il y a violation de territoire ont
refusé en fait de soutenir les sanctions
et on refusait de condamner de manière
très claire la Russie et en fait ce que
ça nous dit ça nous dit aussi que bah
depuis depuis plusieurs décennies le
monde a changé et que alors c'est assez
intéressant parce que c'est à la fois
c'est à la fois une forme de paradoxe de
la mondialisation du mondialisation qui
a été voulue et construite par les
Occidentaux mais dans cette
mondialisation voulue et construite par
les occidentaux il y a eu la possibilité
de l'émergence et émergence économique
d'abord et puis une fois qu'on est
émergent qu'on est un marché on a du
pouvoir aussi et on prétend à ce pouvoir
et on prétend alors pas tellement à
apprendre le pouvoir mais à peser sur
les relations internationales et
aujourd'hui ce que nous disent tous ces
pays et les sanctions en stigmatisées
cette critique ça a été de dire mais
vous ne pouvez plus décider de l'alpha
et de l'oméga de l'avenir du monde on
veut participer à cette décision et en
fait tout l'avenir et toutes les
relations internationales et
probablement la mondialisation
économique vont être dessinées par la
capacité que nous aurons nous à entendre
ce point de vue là et pourquoi je vous
dis c'est directement ça se superpose à
la rivalité Chine États-Unis parce qu'on
voit bien les Russes d'un côté les
Chinois de l'autre un petit peu les
Brésiliens également avec le retour de
Lula surf sur cette vague de
contestation de cet ordre dominé et
construit par les Occidentaux à nous de
savoir aussi proposer des réponses
proposer une ouverture et la possibilité
à ces pays de participer à l'ordre
mondial oui il faut jamais oublier non
plus que la Chine est dans une
entreprise impérialiste nationaliste et
qu'elle investit considérablement en
Europe et que et en Afrique qu'elle est
elle-même en réalité avec la Russie on
parlait de naïveté tout à l'heure je
crois qu'il y a une grande naïveté par
rapport à la stratégie de la Chine car
elle est dans une entreprise
d'investissement à long terme tout ça
pour promouvoir
économique donc il faut savoir et nous
parlions tout à l'heure de souveraineté
de dépendance de l'Europe aujourd'hui il
faut arrêter d'être naïf la Chine va
tenter de nous insérer dans un tissu
d'investissement économique considérable
nous sommes dans un état de dépendance
et c'est cela dont il faut faire
attention l'ancienne Première ministre
qui n'a été que 50 jours le stress était
récemment au Japon britannique
britannique et a dit effectivement que
la Chine aujourd'hui était le véritable
danger et je crois qu'elle a elle a
raison c'est pas uniquement la Russie
c'est aussi cette rivalité Chine Russie
États-Unis qui peut faire de l'Europe
une victime à l'avenir un mot de
conclusion c'est dans le fond d'écran
Chine États-Unis de 2022 on est obligé
de parler de Taïwan les deux peut-être
un grandes raisons dans
l'interventionnisme américain d'une part
il a été économique vendre du GNL à
foison à l'Europe ça lui rapporte mais
d'autre part il y avait aussi les que le
la crainte pour les États-Unis et pour
le reste du monde aussi sans doute que
le ce qui se passait en Ukraine avec la
Russie si jamais
Vladimir Poutine avait réussi sa
blitzkrie que en Ukraine que la Chine le
fasse avec Taiwan et donc très
rapidement et ils sont intervenus pour
pour montrer que ça ne se passerait pas
aussi facilement merci beaucoup merci à
tous encore une fois d'avoir participé à
ce débat Patrick Martin Geny votre livre
l'Europe a-t-elle un avenir on espère
que oui c'est aux éditions
Studyrama voilà je vous dis à demain
pour un nouveau numéro de sens public et
puis votre prochain rendez-vous
politique dans la matinale manuel
Bompard député coordinateur de la France
insoumise face à royalement signé à 8h